feel like I heard you started in
weddings right seen wedding did weddings
and boy do I did I did I'm not a Jewish
I did I did I did all that I did
funerals have you ever done a funeral
it's the worst thing you've ever done in
your life yeah yeah so I I lied about my
age because I thought people wouldn't
hire me so I said it was 18 as though
that was any better to be out with a
bunch of 35 year old men after hours
good night but and I Drive around
illegally in Long Island because the a
junior license so you're not supposed to
be driving at that time and and and yeah
and I knew all the cops are actually
here to talk one time this guy had had
like a heart attack while I was singing
on the dance floor it's not funny I'm
sorry I don't mean a laugh listen to me
in Australia it happened to you it's so
freaking weird
and my bandleader was kind of mean it
was like cracking the whip he was like
the show goes on you keep singing and I
was like but he sniped me at this stop
and he was like made me keep singing and
then the the bride came home and she was
like you're so insensitive
stop singing and I was like I was like
crying and I went over to the Viennese
table and start stuffing my face at
chocolate éclairs just like prayed for
this man he ended up being okay oh my
god oh my god it does suck that when
you're doing a show and all this and
you're like what's happening over there
and you have no idea and then you feel
insensitive and it's not that you just
didn't even know you have any errs in
and all that it's and then another time
these kids in the bar mitzvah they were
throwing food at me and my friend we
were singing we're seeing like I'm so
excited or whatever and they were
throwing food at us and fun we just had
had it so we threw his back this like
chocolate sundae and we ran into the
bathroom and then they like we were in
the bathroom just hiding in there nobody
knew that Greg the family it was like
where are those girls we needed them to
sing but the guys were the little kids
were outside the door waiting to like
smash away I need you to start a podcast
of just random story about your life
like what those two stories were Jim so
it's like that's why I got my education
and just like getting a thicker skin and
you're warming and going with whatever
happens you have that yeah like in
moment yeah I've done some weird stuff
I've never had food thrown at me god
bless I would have I'm not nice like you
I would have not handled that way I've
had it taken my earrings off I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
YouTube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this